[Music]
excellent
thank you um i am tina cormier
i am a remote sensing scientist at
indigo ag
and i'm not going to be talking about
my specific work today but what i want
to talk to you about
is how the geospatial community
views are and how we use r and
how our fits in with all the other tools
that we use before i keep going
i have my twitter handle up there and i
also have
i put all the code behind the million
bar charts you're about to see
into github and
my presentation's there as well
okay so the first thing we need to get
out of the way is that
much like many of you geospatial data
scientists
are a very diverse group we do a lot of
different things
we span many different sectors so
there's finance there's people studying
climate change
agriculture that's what i do
telecommunications
transportation social media kind of
spans the whole gamut
and we don't use just one tool and i'm
sure that
that sounds very familiar to a lot of
you um
so what i kind of wanted to do was
pull the community and figure out
you know is my experience i kind of know
how i work is my experience
uh sort of representative of what's
going on in the broader geospatial
community
or am i some sort of weirdo
don't answer that
[Laughter]
so i created a poll
and i had it live for about a week or
two i don't know
um but basically i asked a whole bunch
of questions like
i put it out on twitter i sent it to my
co-workers previous co-workers you know
anyone that i knew that
works in geospatial and i got
a pretty good number back 307
doesn't qualify me for the big data
workshop or anything like that
but not too bad
uh but what i did like about the results
here is that
the analysts that answered this came
from a huge variety of
or a good swath of sectors we
captured a great deal of experience
levels
and a huge number of roles
and i've tried to kind of distill all
this down what you're seeing here
is by sector
what kind of experience did we capture
so from
left to right it's least experienced to
most and it's a pretty good
swath and we also captured people from
the private sector from academia
non-profit organizations there are a few
people from un organizations that
responded which were really cool
k through 12 education
and if we want to just look at
experience levels
i was pretty impressed that we've got
you know almost the same number of
people
that are just entering the field as
people at the top who have been here for
20 or more years and have a ton of
experience to provide for us
so i was pretty happy with that swath
and i i promise bar charts so there's a
bar chart
if that helps you kind of look at the
distribution of
experience levels of people who answered
this
poll i should have also said at the
beginning
that i make no claims about the
statistical validity of
validity of this poll uh these are
basically
my twitter people so
okay so what kind of jobs do people have
that filled this
out there was a huge list and i tried to
kind of
recode it into a smaller list so we've
got everybody
from academic researchers gis
techs software engineers
data scientists people who are in
management we had a couple of
ctos answer students remote sensing
scientists
educators some statisticians i don't
even know any statisticians so this is
cool
this this survey went out a little
broader than the people that i know
um and so in this graph we're looking at
a cut of
by role who's using scripting and
there's not too much surprising here
almost everybody is
i'm a little surprised at the gis tech
people there's kind of a
bigger group of them who are not coding
just yet and we'll take a look at what
they are doing
um just another this is not a pie chart
i just got sick of bar charts
i'm feeling a little defensive um yeah
so this is just another look at the way
people tackle their work
60 of the participants don't code at all
91 said they do but they don't use r
and the biggest chunk and again these
are people that i
follow or follow me on twitter so
there's a lot of our users
um but a bunch of us said we do we
either do currently code in r
or we have in the past coded in r
so what other tools are we using though
and this is super interesting to me
for analysis so i did two cuts analysis
and cartography because there's a huge
complaint among our users are among
geospatial analysts that are is
difficult for making maps so i wanted to
find out what
what they are doing but for analysis
qgis which is awesome i don't know if
you guys know qgis
but it's an open source geospatial
software program
gui point and click really powerful tons
of contributors
it's a really great program i use it a
lot for mapping
and just for visualizing my data and so
that's sitting at the top of the stack
which was a little bit
surprising to me the biggest competitor
there is esri
and they're a few spots down so
they are a proprietary software company
huge
company many of you who are in spatial
analysis will know who they are
and then there's python and r and
they're kind of close together
but we've got some other things some
people are just natively using
gdel in the command line so that's great
postgres
postgis google earth engine made the
list so this is all
good info things get a little more
compressed when we start looking at
cartography tools here we have two
gooeys up at the top and this is not
surprising we've got qgis up there
again as well as esri and then the third
one down as we start getting into
programming languages
is r and i think you know that's a
tribute to all the work that's gone
into making our such a good programming
language for visualization
and all the control package
contributions
to that end okay so i strayed from a bar
chart
i have to take a timeout here so um
because i'm
not good at making maps and r i pulled
my
twitter friends and was like help me out
here guys send me some cool maps which
you'll see later in the
presentation um but then i heard about
this thing
called tidy tuesday which a lot of you
may know about but if you don't you
should check it out
people in this this community are
amazing they get a data set every week
and they make amazing visualizations
with it and they
often post their code so i stole
someone's code here
kind of to visualize
by role what tools are people using
so what you're seeing here the
percentages are based on the number of
people in that category that filled out
the
poll generally and then the circles i
know you probably can't read the labels
but you can
check my slides later but the circles
represent
how popular that particular tool is
within that
group so you can see that like
let's see for data science r and python
are pretty huge tools but in the
developer community
not so much r and we'll talk about that
a little bit later but this graph just
kind of tries to put all the data
in front of you in a visualization that
asks
who are we talking about and what are
they using for tools
okay so of the people who do program so
i've filtered out the
the folks who aren't programming here
how many of them
have used are or do you currently do
use are and so not surprisingly here
researchers and data scientists are
heavy r users we already know this
and this is a conversation that i've
heard a lot here and
seen a million blog posts about but
developers
are kind of not
so open to r in a lot of cases
and so i i did actually do some
interviews
with some people on my team that are
developers
and elsewhere and we'll get into some of
their feedback
in a few minutes but this is kind of
obvious if you're not using r what are
you doing
you're using python so these are people
who
have never used r and they are
basically using python or javascript
okay so this question basically
asks you know what's missing for r
to make a huge impact or a much bigger
impact in the geospatial community
and so some of this is a little tough to
hear and some of it feels a little bit
inaccurate after some of the talks that
i've been to about
development pipelines and everything but
it does give us some good feedback
about what the like general community is
still
thinking about are and if it
if it's not correct then we need to
figure out how to
change the culture and change people's
thoughts about this so i'll just kind of
read through these
these are quotes that either came off
the survey or came from
me speaking to people but basically
one person said that the number one
limitation
is that no developers no r obviously
that's not
totally true but i think in the general
community
you know hiring good developers is hard
finding good developers is hard
and then making our a requirement for
that makes it even
well impossible according to this person
um
and then we get into like the python
versus our thing which wasn't the
question that i asked but it's sort of
inevitable
uh python is the golden nugget which has
managed to bring together scientists
and developers uh this next person said
r is in niche scripting language
python basically dives deeper into
data science than r dives into
development
a couple more there were a lot of
comments about scaling up
and resource use and the ability to
control resources in memory
um kind of another r versus python
and then a comment about maps there were
a couple comments about
making maps and this didn't have to do
with python so that was nice
change but basically saying that people
are
still sort of using the gui softwares to
do their visualizations
they can pan and zoom around and it's a
little more interactive than
natively trying to use our
so getting on to better news uh
where does our shine see what i did
there
shiny
um so i was obviously polling
geospatial analysts so the number one
response here is
geospatial analysis that's what people
are doing with r and that's what they
think
our strengths are there are a number of
awesome packages for handling spatial
data which we'll get into in a minute
second here was visualization no
surprise there i was very good at that
data wrangling i probably could have
combined statistics and exploratory data
analysis but i didn't
modeling and some people said everything
complete pipeline so that was cool
and a couple other responses there
favorite packages for geo this is more
just for like your
information if you're not using
r for geo these are some really nice
packages that you might want to start
using
the biggest responses were sf and raster
which now play nicely together so that's
awesome also
ggplot map view which i don't even know
what that is
so some of these were helpful for me for
me as well to check out
leaflet t-map rgdl sp is still on there
a lot of people still
are using that um oh some people put
python libraries in there that's why
geopandas has a little star next to it
that's not in our package
they're just like hell bent on getting
python in here
but i didn't want to ignore it so um
this is just kind of some packages that
surprised me or that i didn't know what
they were
um you know you kind of get in your own
little tunnel of
working and you use the packages that
you always use because they work and you
kind of don't know what else is going on
so this survey
introduced me to a few different ones
like stars i do tons of space
spatial temporal analysis and i didn't
even know about this package so
i'm very excited to check that out uh
map deck whose author i think is here
um just learned about that because i
asked for maps on twitter and he
responded so that's awesome and he had a
great
david cooley had a great poster session
last night geosphere i had never heard
of that
again ray shader which i'll show you
some
examples from that in a minute but makes
like amazing 2d and 3d
graphics not just maps but including
maps
yeah awesome so i had never used that
either because i don't usually make maps
in r
but i'm going to now um okay so i've got
some eye candy here i'm not going to
like go through these and explain what
they are because i don't always even
know what they are but here are some
cool maps from ray shader
i put the name of the author and the
code
so these are people that responded to my
twitter call for help
and there were a lot of responses to
choose from and i decided that i would
narrow it down by just
including people that included their
code
so code's all there this one i love
it's a bivariate plot and i won't
it's annotated very nicely so that you
can see
what the colors mean but basically
combinations of different colors
reveal information about two different
variables so
income inequality and high and low
income so the higher the income
and the higher the inequality we're
looking at like this deep purple color
down here so you can see these areas
have
uh people with high income and the
inequality is also
super high and that's just kind of how
you explain these but like what a
beautiful map i don't even think i could
make that ever in any software so
um this one's super cool too uh this
person had to make an orienteering map
and they decided to do it in lord of the
rings
uh theme and they just like made this up
in our
code available
and then there's a couple other examples
that are just like really nice pretty
maps
that you can make with our
um from some very cool
very active people and especially that
tidy tuesday
twitter group this one looks like
stained glass which is pretty cool
this one's from map deck
i don't know how that got in there again
but i worked really hard on that graphic
i just wanted to get a little more
mileage out of it
um yeah i i really thought i don't know
i worked really hard and i stole
people's code and i patched it together
and it was like two in the morning
so don't judge my code if you do look at
it it's really hard to put your code out
there
anyway i'm happy to take questions or
discussion about some of the
things that were found from the survey
perfect thank you
once again if you'd like to submit a
question use the app
app.sli.do i've got a couple questions
for you
any best practices on mapping zip code
data
can you talk a little bit about the data
processing component
what's the ideal stage that data should
get to
whoa um i have to say i've never mapped
zip code data so i don't know if i'm the
best person to
to answer that and that what was the
second part of the
um can you talk about the data
processing component
hard to know what's the ideal stage that
data should get to
i guess it's sort of like any other data
science
situation where you have to do a lot of
pre-processing and cleaning of your data
to get it to a stage where it's actually
useful and i don't think oftentimes you
know geospatial data seems like this big
magical thing
it's not it's there are certain things
you have to know that are specific to it
but other than
other than that it's just another data
science problem
how many of the people who made
complaints about r
do you believe have used the most recent
geospatial packages
like sf yeah probably not many
um a lot of them so you know there's
this tension even in in my group and
this is part of what prompted me to do
this
where the data science team they're we
are writing in
python and or r but the engineering team
is like i only want
python and they don't know r and they
won't look at r so probably not many
they just have this
thought about what it is based on stuff
they've heard
um and probably heard a long time ago so
yeah that's
i think we've got time for one more
question what about
um julia the language julia for
geospatial
yeah um you know no but so
on this graph and on some of the other
graphs i took like
the top responses so on this one 10
people or more had to say it
that they were using it julia did appear
but i think it was
one person i have not coded in julia but
i mean i've heard i've heard good things
but i don't have the experience to
awesome well thank you and please please
thank
tina cormier from indigo